yeah but greg
greg could kill you uh like there was an
uh a lawyer that once
described him as
good looking articulate uh
he said something like he could sit down
with judges and lawyers
have dinner with you and for dessert
he'll kill you
that's how he described greg you know
and we had the tape this this
this uh a lawyer got caught
with heroin got arrested so he
immediately cooperated
and they were interviewing him about all
the guys from the colombo family that he
dealt with
and we had the tape so how do we get
that tape you know
greg's connection got it and this was
became as we look back on
you know uh in time the handwriting was
on the wall
we just couldn't believe it knowing he
was such a killer uh
you know i'll tell you what happened
during the war which i mean really
made it certain but there were things
like greg jr told me that just
weird things that would happen where his
father wasn't part of something the next
day he
found out they all got pinched you know
a lot of that
uh but there's a lot more of that going
on so if he
was protected by the feds that's that's
why they would
that's why the trials would get blown
not only that this agent
was giving us addresses of our enemies
so you're giving he gave us a dirty
agent
he gave us an address so these are all
the things and i'll get to them
of uh the last casualty of the war well
not really the last one last one that we
did then when i was away there were a
couple more
well when we all got arrested uh just
sort of
cleaning up the mess yes so when did
this agent get in trouble
is that how greg him and greg were
together for
many many years like he was working for
the feds for 30 years
it goes all the way back to the
mississippi burning story you ever see
that movie
no i've heard about it i'm getting
familiar with it what's this what is
this can you tell for people who haven't
heard it tell us it's about
uh these three civil service workers
that
uh they're fighting for uh to abolish
uh the the racial right tensions and all
of that
but the ku klux klan in mississippi was
still very strong
and they killed these civil service
workers one was black and i think two
were white
and they buried the bodies the fbi
couldn't get anybody to talk
none of the clans guys would talk so
they recruited greg scarpa
they brought him to mississippi and
it's you could see it in the new york
times this is very public now
he went and the words that were told to
me later on because sometimes the fbi
says more than they should
was that he did unspeakable things yeah
so
you know that leaves you a little
imagination and then later on i heard he
had a knife to their you know their
groin area
uh cut their dicks off that's you know
again you know i wasn't there but
you know these are things that you
pieced together yourself unspeakable
things you had nothing not unspeakable
if you're talking about kkk
though no all right yeah he'd cut his
balls dick off
all right we can smile about it
that's true so anyway he gets uh he
finally gets to the guy
that knows where the bodies were buried
it's like only one guy really knew
okay and i whether it was the second in
command or whatever
and uh so since that day
i used the term cop lunch he had caught
lunch with
to do whatever he wanted in the street
he was never going to get arrested
and he took advantage of that to you
know i mean making
a money-making machine and a killer uh
he was making a good he must have been
getting paid quite a bit to be oh he was
getting paid too
yeah yeah that came out later on in the
trial
uh the fbi agent i won't mention his
name because he did beat the case
the reason he beat the case oh really
was yeah uh
greg's the linda the the his last wife
the one that i was with for 10 years
just about uh
had conflicting stories earlier on and
this is my
deduction she was still on the payroll
to keep her quiet because she knew a lot
about
this agent okay and
once they stopped paying her i think she
got
scorned okay because now she had no
money she was
not living well greg is uh
is dead so she comes clean and admits
what she knew about him
so the things that i knew okay during
the war
he would get he we had this big i don't
know if you're too young to remember
these big shoe phones these big
the stock brokers used to do yeah you
know now everybody has a little
pictures we didn't have phones back then
so
he would call somebody or the person
would call on that phone
and he would refer to the person as his
girlfriend
it's my girlfriend meaning his
connection whoever it was we didn't know
we thought it was a cop based on some of
the information then we thought it could
be somebody on the other side he says
someday i'll tell you
he says but he wouldn't tell us me and
jimmy my partner were the only three
guys were together every day during the
war
nobody else could come near us anymore
because we knew somebody would give us
up
our own friends now to get this over
with would kill us right so we would
we were one the three of us were one and
he uh uh
what was i talking about would i why did
i lose my train of thought the big shoe
phone calling his girlfriend yes so
so we had i had phone records
later on the feds got these phone
records so they know exactly who he was
talking to
okay we had a scanner
which had a secret code like a five or
six digit
pic any five or six numbers random seven
two one six five four three
we had that code so we were listening
to the fbi and local task force police
as they were following us and our
enemies we knew when they were behind us
we knew where they were going so how did
we get this
then it came a little later on we were
getting this
information that had to be from
surveillance like
it came back like we knew exactly what
time this guy leaves his house
3 40 in the morning because he goes to
the school bus company that he owns
okay we get there at three 20
3 40 the lights of the [ __ ] turn on
somebody was doing surveillance so that
information later on we knew
came from him right we also had
uh access to fbi
badges and credentials because he's
there was one guy he wanted to go
and call him out of the house as the fbi
and get him in the car and once he gets
put in the car greg was going to be
sitting in the car
i mean picture that scene how that guy
would have felt
no he's in cuffs and he's sitting
between me and greg you know because
the guy knew us actually was wild bill
billy catola
and he knew me so i couldn't go to the
door
but there were a few guys that he didn't
know that would dress in cheaper suits
than we usually wear and
go up to the door and show the
credentials and call them out and
tell them we're not going to cuff you in
the house you know sometimes the fbi
would do that
just we'll cuff you outside you know if
they want to be nice
uh not to do to do that in front of the
family you know because they know we're
not
typically going to shoot it out with
them right so anyway
we had this whole plan so all these
different things led to fbi
okay later on two of the agents
themselves
were sitting in the office with this
agent
and they have an episode on the sopranos
about this
when the biggest hit of the war happened
nikki black
nicki granzio who was vic's
choice for council yeah okay
when we got him he banged the desk
the agent and he says we're gonna win
this thing
we're gonna win this thing the other
agent says
we like and then they started
putting pieces together too we had this
is
what what made them know there's one
agent underneath this was a supervising
agent who's bad
the underneath the agent the name's
chris does not only give his last name
uh gets an address from surveillance of
where vicarine is hiding out
that's our number one target if we kill
vic the war is over
right okay he
greg gets this address okay
we go there there's no house on the lot
it's a wrong address so
the only person chris gave that wrong
address to
was his superior how does greg wind up
with the same exact wrong address
so now they knew that they saw they
followed greg there or something well
no just he only chris didn't give it to
greg
okay this address
he gave the address from surveillance
this is where to to his superior
oh right right so that's the only right
so he's wondering how greg
got that address you know and this all
came out in the trial later on
you know that's how you know how did
greg initially get like if he had that
protection how did that protection
dissolve
because the other agents found out that
chris was dirty
well well now chris wasn't his superior
his superiority
yes and you will give him partially that
partially that we don't know him and
uh well you know it's alleged
yeah his name's lin okay you know i i
see i don't like to come on in and
because he beat he beat the case
okay so he isn't he doesn't speak about
it publicly
he does he does he wrote a book you can
read the book it's called deal with the
devil
deal with the doe yeah okay yeah uh and
he's done documentaries
oh so he's out there i mean yeah just uh
just you you can research and find his
name
it's his first name
i